I legit would worry if my kid got like addicted to porn,
because like you hear about the adults who get addicted to porn,
like Tommy Cruz's addicted to porn. Right. Was he? Yeah,
he was addicted to porn, I think. Um, and there was generally like,
I sent you a link. So I, I was on YouTube and there's just a video,
something called, like coming clean or something. Remember it.
And it was just this guy who was just like, no one,
no one had exposed him on YouTube. No one had said anything.
He just came out with it. He was just like, I'm addicted to porn guys.
I'm going broke because he's like, Oh, you had a few million.
And he was just like, Oh yeah. Oh, I do remember that.
He was that guy who was in like a happy relationship.
She wasn't married was me happily married. He wasn't, he wasn't like a,
it was like a buff. Really good looking dude. Yeah.
And he was just like, yes. So like, I'm just like horribly addicted to porn.
He just, he just spent his money on chatter.
Bay so bad for the dude. And it's like, you know,
had this like come out any other way. People probably would've mocked him,
but he, you know,
he spoke about it himself and he kind of felt like really bad for the dude.
You're like, I can't, I,
I can't sympathize per se because I would not sympathize. I, I can't, you know,
experience that myself. But like, I was like, dude,
I would never want that on like my kid or something to be like,
cripplingly addicted to like virtual video porn. Right.
Whatever. I don't, I feel so bad about it.
I think it especially hurts considering the fact that like,
he's going broke because of it as well.
And luckily the guy like, the video is really good. I break my watch again,
like just to like, I dunno. And, and his wife was like understanding of it.
And then she helped like walk him through it. I just,
it was really sweet and I hope the guy's doing better now. I've, I've no idea.
I didn't watch any of the videos, but like,
how'd you even get to a point when you ride Gary? Like what, what, what is,
what is the line where you were addiction?
What is a porn addiction? You know? It's, is it how snap.
It's going to kill me for that job?
Yeah. It's like, is it to the point where it's like,
you're spending so much money that it's like putting a dent on your car to spend
money on porn? I mean, aside from.
You, off. Yeah.
I can handle the hot say I've never spent any money on Poland.
I feel like that is like a big line to cross where you're comfortable getting
your credit card out to put in. Right. That's like just a lie.
I don't want to cross. And I'd be really sad in my son or my daughter. If I,
they were like, you have got a premium Brasa subscription. Like why.
Y yeah. I don't know what it like to me spending money on like Kensai games or
something. I completely understandable.
As soon as you spend money on like, I guess real life porn,
for some reason that just flips a switch me to be like, how, why?
I think it's because they're like, unlike irrigators,
like hand-eye and stuff like that.
There are so many options to get the same experience for free. That's it? Right.
Because I've, I'm guessing none of us have ever actually bought a hint. I DVD.
Well, I did. I did. Oh, okay. Okay.
I bought the classic. I bought mother knows breasts. Did you actually,
I actually bought it. Yeah. I bought a physical cough.
Cause obviously the podcast. Yeah. I, it hasn't arrived yet because I was like,
I noticed that the licensor who's selling it. Uh,
they eventually delist the older ones and I thought, well,
I've got to get a copy of mother's breast just in case it goes into that.
That doesn't count because you've already seen, I'm not gonna Jack off to it.
It's going to be pristine condition. I bought it to preserve.
This is the you're going to frame.
And you're going to begin to show your kids and be like, kids cost me.
$50. Yeah. Well.
That's understandable. Right? Like, no,
one's going to frame their Brazos subscription on a wall. Right. So it's like,
there are people out there, but.
Because it's like, uh, you know, you hear about those, you know,
that'd be like politician scandals, and they'd be like,
he spent $40,000 on porn. I'm like, I don't even know how you would do that. Or.
You stop to spend that much money on porn. I don't.
Even know how you go about how would you.
What I want to know is how would you not have enough sources of porn that you
need to spend money?
Well, I think a lot of people want like specific porn, right?
Like I think again, like this is where a lot of like independent, craziest.
No, no, that's, that's totally the reasonable. I only fans this thing because I.
Well, I would never pay $20 for something on a Jack off dude. Right, right.
Yeah. I mean, like for me, like I can't,
I can understand why people would want to support independent creators.
Like for example, only fans or something, because you know, there,
there is that parasocial relationship in there.
And I can totally understand why people would want to spend money on that. Um,
I don't understand like browser subscriptions or just like when there is no,
parasocial where there is no social relationship.
I would almost argue that only fans and all those parasocial relationships are
way worse off than getting a brand subscription.
I agree with Judy I've it is a dangerous line.
I don't even like dislike anything about it. I just feel sad.
But I look at it all. Like, I just feel sorry for everyone. Like, I mean,
other than the creators are making bank right. Good for them.
Like totally understandable. The grind you do what you gotta do. But like,
when you look at some of these guys and you see what some of them say online,
like, you just feel sad for them. Like.
This isn't to demerit any like, Oh, I don't.
Work or anything like that. This is a lot of the stuff they make is awesome.
And a lot of you put a lot of work into it. I just feel [inaudible].
It's a dangerous line that I don't want to cross.
I want to go into that. Cause if you, if you pay for one,
I feel like you'll do it again. I'll probably buy another one.
And it's dangerous for the creator as well, because then you get, you know,
some of these supporters who get a little too comfortable with it and try and
start crossing. Like, I can't imagine,
I can't imagine what they have to deal with on the day or may get huge respect
to them. Every type of like creepy dude, you know,
thinking that just because they paid like a grandiose amount of money to this
creator that suddenly they're like best friends, you know,
when that's just not how it works.
Few of them on Twitter, this is pretty good to see like, Oh God,
what do you see? But like, just seeing what they get up to is like it, I mean,
it's sad. Some of the they got to deal with just to like,
you got to like fight just to take, to have people take you seriously.
Oh my God. Yeah.
Yeah. Cause the thing is,
I would like to think that everyone's end goal for watching porn is like, uh,
you know,
an offset for being able to go into like a happy relationship where you just
feel satisfied and um, and like happy with banjo life. So, you know,
you stop wanting to be horny.
You just be happy. Yeah. I'm saying Bandon, horny, happy.
I feel like if you go out and pay for porn,
you're crossing a dangerous line where I've no return, right?
Not that you can't return from it, but you're, you're getting comfortable.
And not be dangerous. I'm just perceive it to myself. Yeah. I mean,
that sounds dangerous. Everyone has, everyone has different.
Line. This is my line as well. Where if I go out and cross this line,
it's the line that I'm not comfortable with myself being about. And you know,
some people are comfortable and I'm sure there's healthy people out there who,
you know, have.
I'm sure that's the thing with the addiction thing, right? Like it's like 95,
95% of people are totally capable of self-regulating and not
over-consuming things,
but there's a good amount of people out there where they find that one thing
that just breaks them, they just can't stop. Like, it's just what it is.
Yeah. And it's just, we go back to the point of how would you recognize what,
what point is too far?
Is it when your life is being actively ruined or when you just can't find a
happy relationship?
Yeah. Which is like, again, why like going back to that video,
like massive props to the dude for being able to like stop himself and be like,
you know what? This is getting out of hand, realizing that it's appalling,
you know, honestly, like I, to me,
I was just amazed that he was willing to talk about that publicly. And you know,
to me, I was like, that's like,
that's like pretty big bowls to come out and be like, listen guys,
I'm addicted to porn knowing that people are gonna meme you. Yeah. But in,
in reality, you know,
there's probably a lot of people going through that and I have massive respect.
The guy coming out. And I think I remember as well,
like from what I saw hardly any meaning at all,
the comments were really positive.
It's again, like w when the stuff is sensitive,
people don't want to talk about it. Cause they mean it.
But it's really important to have people come out and be like, listen,
this is a real thing. I'm like, it's me over.
Yeah. It's slowly, it's the exact same thing with, for example, Gacha addiction,
you know, we, we can meme the out of it. But if someone has an issue,
you should take it seriously.
And you shouldn't just think that people are gonna mock you and meme the out of
you. Some people will listen to anything is never good. Some people will,
but the good people out there will actually understand that. You know,
you can have an embarrassing problem sometimes. Uh,
sometimes it's hard to tell when you've gone too far.
Yo Joey plays our games. You know, like, I feel sorry for him, you know,
you play leagues clean, clean, by the way,
you it's like duality of man. Right. Played a ranked game on my account.
And like for four or five months,